TAKASHI MATSUO: Hi.
I'm Takashi Matsuo, Developer
Advocate on App Engine.
DANNY HERMES: And I'm Danny
Hermes, Developer Programs
Engineer on App Engine.
TAKASHI MATSUO: Yeah.
Today we're going to have our
talk about OAuth2 Decorator.
And speaking of OAuth2, I had
an experience a year ago.
I wrote a sample App Engine
application using Google class
API with or without
OAuth2 flow.
And it was not a very
bad experience.
It was just easy as checking
out their Google+ Client
Library and copy it to your
project directory and tweak
the setting up.
But I almost forgot
about the details.
So I'm not eligible to
talk about that.
So--
DANNY HERMES: Here I go
with the details.
TAKASHI MATSUO: So go ahead.
DANNY HERMES: So OAuth,
in general--
OAuth1 first, and now OAuth2 has
caused a lot of people a
lot of pain.
And people say, the only thing
worse than OAuth2 is OAuth1.
So we want to make these tools
as easy as possible for you
guys, our developers,
to actually use it.
And think about building
features into your
applications, rather than
actually having to figure out
how OAuth works every
single time.
So I'm going to try to go
through from beginning to end
on how you would develop an
application using the OAuth2
Decorator in the Python
runtime of App Engine.
OK?
TAKASHI MATSUO: OK.
DANNY HERMES: So the first
thing you need to do when
using OAuth is tell Google,
hey, I have an application
that's going to be
performing OAuth.
So I will go to the Google
API's console.
It can be found at
code.google.com/apis/console.
It takes me to a project I've
already got going, but we'll
create a new one
just for this.
So my new one we will call,
GDL Dummy Project.
You guys aren't dummies.
The project is a dummy.
And as it loads, as it loads.
OK.
There we go.
So this is a list of services
that I will
actually be able to call.
A list of Google APIs
that I'll be able to
call with this project.
Now, I haven't told you this
yet, but I'm going to be
calling the Tasks API.
The Tasks API is a way for you
to keep track of things that
you're doing.
Or for your application to help
users track things that
they're doing when they want
to get them done by, when
they've completed them,
a general task list.
So we're going to go down
and find the Tasks API.
There it is.
And click that button.
It goes from on to off.
Now, had I not done this--
actually making requests to
the Tasks API with an
application using this API
Console Project would give
me 403 forbidden error.
Even if I were to have a valid
OAuth token, I would still not
have access to the API because
I wouldn't have turned the
service on.
Now, when I was preparing for
this, it took me about two
minutes to actually realize
that I had forgot
to check this box.
So it's very important to opt in
to all the APIs that you're
going to be using that
are on this list.
So the next thing
is API Access.
So right now we have an API key,
but we need a Client ID
and a Client Secret because this
Client ID and this Client
Secret is how we actually
perform the OAuth dance.
And we need to actually give
this to our Decorator when we
construct it in our code.
So we're going to create it
before we actually have to
have one in our code.
OK?
So we're just going to
be using local hosts.
So for our homepage
http://localhost8080.
This will be local only, but if
you had an App Engine app,
your app ID dot app [INAUDIBLE]
dot com would be
your homepage.
And our product Dummy Task
App is what it is.
And we don't actually
need a logo.
So then it's going to ask us if
it's a web application, a
service account, or an installed
application.
So this is going to be a web
application, obviously, hosted
on App Engine.
And the actual site is
localhost:8080, as I said before.
And what we'll get for
a redirect URI--
I don't know if people can see
it, but it's http://localhost
:8080/oauth2callback.
And this is actually the default
callback used to
handle a response from
Google when the
OAuth2 dance is complete.
So for those who aren't entirely
familiar with OAuth,
I'm not going to go too much
into detail about it because
we're really talking about App
Engine with OAuth, not OAuth
as a standalone.
But what happens is your
application with this Client
ID and this Client Secret that
we're trying to get will
actually send a request to a
Google URL that your user can
authorize your application
or not.
Right?
And then after that, if the user
says Allow Access, they
get redirected to your
application to a
URI that you specify.
So in this case, we specify
//oauth2callback.
And at /oauth2callback we
actually have to handle the
redirect from the Google OAuth2
part of the handshake
and determine whether or not
we have a valid user.
And that is what the OAuth2
Decorator is going
to allow us to do.
So here I'm going to go
create this Client ID.
OK, cool.
So now we have a Client ID
and a Client Secret.
And we have a few other things,
like this redirect URI
that we just specified.
And if we were going to be using
a Google API directly
from JavaScript, we also
have an origin, which
is trusted by Google.
So we're just going to leave
this like that for now.
And we're going to go hop into
our App Engine and actually
start building an application.
Do you have a question?
TAKASHI MATSUO: No.
No.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
I thought I heard Takashi making
a noise like he wanted
to talk, but apparently he
didn't have a question.
All right, cool.
So I'm here programming
on my Mac.
And I've got a Google App
Engine Launcher open.
And I have already loaded up the
project that I'm going to
be working on, the app.
So just to start us out, we've
got a simple application.
It's running Python 2.7.
If people are still on Python
2.5, I strongly encourage
going to Python 2.7.
And for all paths--
all routes--
we're just using main.py
via this file.
And all it's doing is
saying, hello GDL.
So let's run that.
And we're going to take
this simple main.py.
And we're going to turn it into
our application that uses
the OAuth2 Decorator.
So let's just go to
localhost:8080.
There we go.
Hello, GDL!
OK.
Great.
So now we want to add
some of the things
provided for OAuth2.
So what we actually want to use
to interact with Google
APIs is a library called the
Google API Python Client.
So the Google API Python Client
is a library used for
Python to actually interact
with Google APIs, and it
actually provides this
thing we want.
So in order to use it
with App Engine,
there's a specific download.
It's on the download's
page of the product--
project.
Excuse me.
And it's called full
dependencies build for Google
App Engine projects with version
1.0 of this library.
So I'm going to go grab this.
I'm going to copy the address
of the download.
And I will just wget it into my
directory of the project.
And then I'm going
to just unzip it.
And by doing this, you're
actually able to have all the
dependencies that you need.
So I just did a quick [? LS ?]
in the directory.
And we have OAuth2 Client URI
template, http:web2, the main
dependencies needed
to actually use
Google API Python Client.
So that's the first step.
Now once we've done
that, we can start
importing things from it.
So to actually build a service
object, call Google API from
the API Client package provided
with this library,
we're going to import a
method called Build.
OK?
TAKASHI MATSUO: OK.
DANNY HERMES: And then from
the OAuth2 Client Package,
within the App Engine module,
we're going to import this
OAuth2 Decorator.
Now, I have some notes where
I can check this later.
There may be some typos, or
maybe I'm capitalizing
something wrong,
but we'll see.
That's the fun of a
live demo, right?
And using these two, we can
accomplish pretty much
everything we want
to accomplish.
So the first thing we'll do--
we'll have a Decorator, which
is an instance of OAuth2
Decorator.
And here we need to pass in
our Client ID, our Client
Secret, and then also a scope.
And this scope is going
to give us access to
a particular thing.
So since we're using the
Tasks API, we actually
need a Tasks Scope.
I mentioned before that had we
not turned on that Tasks
service, then we would
have got a 403.
By the same token, if we
request an OAuth2 token
without the correct scope, and
we make an API request that
needs that scope, then that
will, of course, be rejected.
So we're going to have to
specify a specific scope.
OK.
So first the Client ID-- we'll
go back to the console.
We see here my Client
ID, 1 0, et cetera.
I'm just going to fill
that in as a string.
Oh, man.
It's a long string.
I don't like exceeding 80
characters, 80 columns.
So we're going to do that.
It's a bit--
how to say?
It's not so big a deal,
but I don't like it.
OK.
And then we go get our Client
Secret from the same page,
VMJ5FD, et cetera.
Now, when you're developing
applications, don't commit
these Client Secrets to
open source projects.
Don't leave them out
in the open.
Don't expose them in
JavaScript or HTML.
These are secret, right?
For the purposes of this demo,
I'm letting you all see
because this project on the
Google API's Console, I'm just
going to throw away
after this.
But in general, this
is a secret.
And this is how you're actually
keeping the OAuth
handshake that you do
with Google secure.
By loading it into main.py, it's
known server-side, so you
can actually perform the
authentication server-side.
But you definitely don't want to
expose this client-side or,
like I said, as part of an
open source project.
And as the final keyword
argument to the OAuth2
Decorator Constructor, we're
going to pass in the scope.
So the scope we want here is--
I don't know exactly if
this is what it is.
But this is approximately
what it is.
It's the scope for Tasks,
https://www.goog
leapis.com/off/tasks.
I believe that's what it is.
But we'll see.
If we get a failure,
we get a failure.
That's the fun, the
fun of this.
TAKASHI MATSUO: Looks-- yeah.
Looks correct.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
There we go.
Honestly, I could google it, but
I'd rather take my chances
just for your benefit of seeing
how you really debug
these things.
MALE SPEAKER: We'll do a live.
DANNY HERMES: We'll
do it live.
I'll write it.
We'll do it live.
If you don't know the reference,
you should google
that exact phrase.
And then, after building the
Decorator, we actually need to
interact with Google APIs.
Actually before I go about doing
this, let's just use
this Decorator.
So there are two particular
ways we use the Decorator.
We can either require--
that particular route is
authenticated with OAuth.
Or we can say that we're aware
whether or not it is.
OK?
So for this one, we're just
going to require that the main
page Handler actually is
decorated with OAuth.
And hence, any requests
that come through--
if the user is either, A, not
signed in, or, B, the
signed-in user has not actually
done the OAuth dance
with the application, then this
will first happen before
they can actually
visit this page.
OK?
So now, I've got
this Decorator,
which we hope works.
Maybe it will.
Maybe it won't.
And we're requiring that in
order for somebody to visit
the main page of our
application, they are signed
in via OAuth.
OK?
So now, let's go back to this
main page and reload.
Ah, wonderful.
So something went wrong.
What went wrong?
OK.
My import was wrong.
I know what it was.
So I said it was in the
API Client Package.
It's not.
It's in the discovery modules
in the API Client Package.
So that's easy to debug.
For those unclear on what I did
so quickly, I went to my
handy dandy Google App
Engine Launcher.
I clicked Logs.
And then I went to my
logs to actually see
what was going on.
And it told me Import Error.
Can't Import Name Built.
And that jogged my memory.
Now, when you're doing this on
your own, you won't be typing
this from scratch.
You'll be referring to
our documentation
and things like this.
So hopefully these sorts
of things don't happen.
Ah, wonderful.
TAKASHI MATSUO: Oh yeah.
DANNY HERMES: Great.
So what happened here,
I refreshed the page.
I'm no longer on local host.
I'm on accounts.google.com/--
this giant long URI containing
all the information Google
needs to actually perform
OAuth specific to my
application and specific to
actually the scope I needed.
So you see here Dummy Task App,
the name we gave it in
the API's Console, is requesting
permission to
manage your tasks.
So since we see Manager Task,
we know we didn't
screw up the scope.
We have the scope
that we needed.
And in addition to this, it
wants to perform these when
I'm not using the application.
So the default value of offline
is used for access,
which means that if the
application is going to manage
my tasks, maybe I can set an
alarm-- say like, wake me up
or something like this.
Maybe that would be something
worthwhile to do
with the Tasks API.
I'm hinting at the future of
the rest of this talk.
So, oh.
What went wrong?
I know what went wrong.
But this is, again, part of the
debugging process, right?
So what happened is we got
localhost:8080 OAuth2 Callback.
And now, this is what Google
knows to redirect for our
application.
And this is what we, in the API
console, said we wanted to
redirect to.
So why doesn't this work?
Well, if we look at our
application code, the only
route we're serving is slash
root, the root of our
application.
Right?
So we actually need to serve
the route, OAuth2 Callback.
But have no fear.
You don't have to figure out how
you might do this because
the Decorator does all of it.
OK?
So we'll add another handler.
So the route that we're actually
going to use is
decorator.callback_url.
Is this what it is?
Now, this one I want
to double check.
Oh.
It's not on the thing
that Takashi's got.
TAKASHI MATSUO: Oh,
yeah, yeah.
DANNY HERMES: Let me quick
pull up my reference.
I'm cheating, but that's OK.
There we go.
Callback path.
There are way too many
characters in
this for me to memorize.
Sorry, folks.
So let me explain what I've just
done after I've got it
formatted to my liking.
OK.
So the path is
decorator.callback_path.
Now, we don't actually have to
specify callback_path, but if
we had wanted to, we could use
callback_path= some other
string when we actually
construct the Decorator.
But the default value of
callback_path is the same
default that the Google API
Console used, OAuth2 Callback.
So we don't have to
worry about that.
And then,
decorator.callback_handler
actually gives us a handler
to deal with this traffic.
So now that we've updated it to
actually be able to handle
that route, let's
try this again--
debugged.
Ah.
What went wrong?
I know what went wrong.
I didn't close a bracket.
My bad.
Bracket closed.
There we go.
OK.
So we're back to where
we were before.
The same accounts.google.com
OAuth page.
Again, with the correct
scope, the Task Scope.
And we're going to
allow access.
Great.
So nothing changed.
I didn't actually change
the content of
this, but we are actually--
and I can show you
guys real quick.
I'll go to the Admin Console
for this application.
That is too big.
And if I click List Entities,
we'll see that I actually have
an entity that is a Credentials
Model for my
application.
So I've actually now got OAuth
credentials stored for the
user that I'm signed in as.
OK?
Great.
We've got credentials.
Now, we want to do something
with them, right?
TAKASHI MATSUO: Yeah.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
So instead of being boring and
saying, hello, GDL, I'm going
to actually go get all the tasks
for the signed-in user
and display them to him.
That's somewhat simple, right?
So we're going to do this.
So in order to do this, I'll go
back and do the other thing
that I started to.
I'm going to create a service
object to actually interact
with Google APIs.
And in particular, we want to
interact with the Tasks API.
So this method build, which we
imported incorrectly, and now
we're importing correctly, takes
an API name and an API
version and spits out an object
that you can interact
with that API with.
So the API name is tasks
and the version is v1.
So in order to build that,
we simply call
service=build tasks, v1.
I'm going to refresh
this to make sure--
OK.
We're all good with that.
OK, great.
And now using this service, the
Tasks API has a resource
called Tasks.
And within that resource,
it has several methods.
The one we want to use, in
particular, is the list
method, right?
So let me get my handy dandy
reference just for my sake.
There, again, too much here
for me to go from memory.
But so what we do here--
we take our service object,
service.tasks.
If we call that with no
argument, it gives us the
sub-resource of the
API, called Tasks.
And this is a way for
users to actually
interact with their tasks.
And now, within that resource,
we have this list method,
which actually allows users to
list the tasks they have.
And so we want a list of
our tasks from the
default task list.
So into the method list, we
pass tasklist=@default.
And that gives us all the tasks
that we would have in
the list that we see in Gmail,
for example, when we look at
the default task
list in Gmail.
And in order to execute
this, we want to use
the signed-in user.
And we know, since we've
specified the decorator.oauth
required that there will be a
signed-in user if we get to
actually run this method.
Right?
So when we actually execute this
method after passing in
the argument tasklist= to the
list method, we're actually
going to execute this by calling
.execute, and passing
in as our HTTP object, our
authenticated object for
making this request, passing
the token that we've just
gotten, we're going to just
simply pass in decorator.http.
Now, decorator.http--
decorator.http, the method,
is just a method from the
Decorator Object that we created
in the Global Scope
before we actually created
any of our handlers.
But when we actually call that
method, it is able to imply
and authenticate an
HTTP instance
from the current context.
So this exact handler could have
decorator.http correspond
to a different user, depending
on who makes it.
Excuse me.
Which user is actually having
the request served by
mainpage.get.
So the point is that
decorator.http depends on the
current context and will
actually give you an
authenticated HTTP object
for the current user.
So great.
We're going to call this.
And we'll get a list of tasks.
I'm going to pop this to the
next line, so we don't go over
80 columns.
Now, this list of tasks will
have a lot of things in it.
Rather than going through and
taking out the parts we want,
I'm just going to show you
the whole thing for now.
So I've imported pretty print or
pprint in Python, so we can
print what we get back in a
somewhat user-readable format.
So instead of hello, GDL,
I'm going to write
prettyprint.pformat of the
response we got back.
Sound good?
TAKASHI MATSUO: Yeah.
DANNY HERMES: Sounds good.
All right.
So we'll go back here.
Hope we didn't make
any mistakes.
Maybe we did.
Maybe we didn't, but
that's the great
thing of a live demo.
Loading, loading, awesome.
So this is what the response
looks like.
So we have a tag.
We have items as another key.
And then, down here
we have a kind.
But really the only thing
we want is items.
So this list of items gives us
a list of all our tasks.
And then from there, we have
some other keys, like when the
task is due, the ID of the
task, the position of the
task, and most importantly,
the title of the task.
So in reality, instead of
displaying everything, we
would rather just go
get the items.
So items=tasks--
task is a dictionary, so
we can call task.get.
Give it our key items
that we see here.
And if that fails, we'll just
say, get [? the empty ?]
list instead.
And then, the response we would
want to send back, and
since we're--
I didn't mention this, but we're
sending back text plain.
So rather than actually trying
to render HTML, is just going
to render plain text
in the browser.
And so we can use new line
characters without having to
use the HTML BR character,
right?
It's somewhat of a benefit.
So for each task in Tasks,
there we go.
TAKASHI MATSUO: Items.
No?
DANNY HERMES: Sorry.
You're exactly right.
Good call.
My bad.
That was about to be another
bug, but Takashi jumped right
in front of that.
And saved us that tiny bit
of time for that bug.
So for each task in items, we're
actually just going to
get the title.
And fall back to the empty
string, if there is no title.
And then, we will join
these by a new line
character in Python.
Newline.join this
list of titles.
So if I call this, instead
using that.
Oh.
I didn't actually change--
TAKASHI MATSUO: It's
still showing--
DANNY HERMES: You're right.
TAKASHI MATSUO: [INAUDIBLE].
DANNY HERMES: I never
change what gets
written to the response.
So instead of pprint.pprint
[INAUDIBLE], I actually need
to change to response.
Thank you, Takashi.
Bug number two that he found.
So make the request again now.
And then we see, Take a nap.
I've got two minutes.
I kind of want to write a
handler that will let me
insert another task.
And then, we'll come
back to this.
Though, I think we should open
the floor to questions.
Really what I wanted you guys
to see was using the OAuth2
Decorator is as simple as
getting a Client ID and a
Client Secret and specifying
your scope.
And once you have that
Decorator, you can use it in
cases like this,
[? decorator.oauthrequired. ?]
And once you have actually
required that your users are
signed in with OAuth, you can
do things like we did here
with tasks=service.tasks,
et cetera.
And you can execute these with
authenticated HTTP objects
that you don't have to
worry about creating.
You don't have to worry about
persisting the credentials for
your users.
It's all done by the
Decorator for you.
And it's super handy.
I will make one other
quick note.
This stuff is all documented.
If you just go ahead--
If you go to
developers.google.com, and you
search for OAuth2 Decorator--
developers.google.com actually
has really great search, if
people weren't aware.
So if you go and you search for
OAuth2 Decorator, the very
first hit, using Google App
Engine, will give you all this
that we just gave
you and more.
And it will give you plenty
of other situations.
So another situation,
other than OAuth
Required, is OAuth Aware.
So rather than actually
requiring the user go through
the Flow, you find out if
the current user has
gone through the Flow.
And if they have, you
do one thing.
You serve, maybe, their tasks.
And if they haven't, you say,
hey, you haven't gone through
the Flow yet.
Do you want to, or do you just
want to look around?
Do you want to read some
more, et cetera.
And it's really up to you.
So I encourage you go to
the documentation.
If people want us to see us
do another live demo doing
similar things, we would
be happy to, because we
acknowledge that the
OAuth dance is
not the easiest thing.
And we want to help make
it easier for you guys.
So it's already 9:30, but let's
try to answer a few
questions-- one or two questions
from moderator.
Do you have any particular
preferences on what you'd like
to do, Takashi?
TAKASHI MATSUO: Sure.
Yeah.
Here's a question, which is--
DANNY HERMES: Let me read it,
and you can answer it.
This guy?
TAKASHI MATSUO: Yeah.
Probably, yeah.
DANNY HERMES: So it says, I know
this session is focused
on consuming Google APIs, but
I was wondering if these
concepts apply to third party
APIs also supporting OAuth2?
Or if a different toolset
is needed.
Many thanks.
From [? Zugaldia ?]
in Washington, DC.
Sorry if I butchered
that name.
So do you want me
to answer this?
Or did you want to
answer this?
Or I'd be happy to.
So these are specific to Google
APIs, but they're not
actually explicitly specific
to Google APIs.
So the Google API Python Client
Library can be used
with any discovery-based API.
And so what's happening when
we call build tasks v1, it
actually goes and retrieves
a discovery document.
And from there, it can create
all the necessary things like,
service.tasks.lists that
we saw, right?
But if any other discovery-based
API that isn't
from Google, if you wish to use
that, in addition to Tasks
v1, you would specify a specific
URI template that
those can be inserted into,
which would let you retrieve a
discovery document.
And that would still work.
And then, when you would create
your Decorator, in
addition to a Client ID and a
scope, you would also specify
a token URI and an Auth URI.
And both of these are official
parts of the OAuth2 spec,
which has nothing to
do with Google.
It's just a general Auth
spec on the web.
But this library is specific for
Discovery APIs, but not to
Google APIs.
I see a Cloud Endpoints
question.
Can I take that?
I've been working a lot
on Cloud Endpoints.
TAKASHI MATSUO: Do you guys plan
on extending App Engine--
DANNY HERMES: I see.
TAKASHI MATSUO: [INAUDIBLE]
OAuth 2.0.
I know it's already supported in
Cloud Endpoints, so my best
guess would be yes, but thought
I'd ask anyway.
DANNY HERMES: Now, I understand
why Takashi had
scrolled down.
We don't generally
give estimates or
comments on new features.
So sorry.
Can't answer that one, but we
are serious about OAuth2.
So do we want to wrap up, or
do we want to do one more?
TAKASHI MATSUO: Yeah.
So one more.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
I'll read it.
You'll answer it, yeah?
TAKASHI MATSUO: What is the
best practice pattern for
decorating a POST handler?
For example, after the
OAuth dance, the
original post is gone.
So is it redirected
to get handler the
right things to do?
Is the Decorator helpful
with this at all?
DANNY HERMES: So tell me if
you disagree with this.
Redirecting from a POST
handler is not good.
Don't do this.
That's not the point of POST.
And if you're using POST within
your application for
persisting data, creating new
things in your data store, you
don't want to redirect
after this, right?
The point of-- you can still
use the Decorator.
And given more time, I was going
to show you guys this,
but you can still use the
Decorator on a POST handler in
the exact same fashion.
And you can still call Decorator
to HTTP and make
these requests, but from a POST
handler you'd be doing
something more like inserting an
object, rather than listing
some titles or some tasks
as we saw here, right?
So after you complete the
insertion, you would give some
response back to whatever
the caller was.
So your POST request, maybe,
would be called asynchronously
from your UI, right?
And so the best practice is you
can use the Decorator in
exactly the same fashion, but
doing a redirect is not
something you want to do.
I guess using the OAuth Aware
handler is probably better.
And if you're using OAuth
Aware, you won't get
redirected.
And maybe that's really what the
heart of the question was
is, will that redirect happen
if I use OAuth Required?
So if you use OAuth Aware on
your POST handler, then you
can check if decorator.
has credentials.
And if it has credentials, you
can do what you would have
done in the required case.
And if it doesn't have
credentials, you can serve a
simple response, like a 400.
And maybe give adjacent error
message that smart clients,
like your UI, could consume
and actually
do something with.
Sound good?
TAKASHI MATSUO: Yeah.
I think so.
DANNY HERMES: Do you have any
other clarifications or
contradictions to what I said?
Takashi knows way more than
I do about this stuff.
TAKASHI MATSUO: No.
What he's asking is, whether the
payload is still there or
not on the POST handler?
DANNY HERMES: What?
How do you mean?
TAKASHI MATSUO: So when the
redirect happens on the POST
handler after coming
back to the--
DANNY HERMES: So--
TAKASHI MATSUO: --their
callback
URL, the payload will--
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
TAKASHI MATSUO: --be
lost, right?
DANNY HERMES: I believe it will
be lost, but you don't
want to actually redirect
a POST handler, right?
You want to make it so that when
the POST request comes
in, the cookies set in that POST
request from your user
session will be able
to be used.
And if there are no cookies with
that POST request, then
you just give an
error message.
So like I sort of stumbled
through at the beginning of my
answer, you don't
actually want--
you don't actually want to be
doing a redirect from a POST
for the exact reason
that Takashi said.
The payload won't make it
through a redirect to a third
party and then back to you.
So you want to be able to
use this payload via
decorator.oauth_aware.
And if you can't, then you
just serve an error.
TAKASHI MATSUO: OK.
DANNY HERMES: Thanks for
the clarification.
TAKASHI MATSUO: No problem.
DANNY HERMES: Thanks
everybody.
TAKASHI MATSUO: Yeah.
DANNY HERMES: It was great.
Have a great new year.
This will be our last
GDL of 2012.
And we hope to do many
more in 2013.
TAKASHI MATSUO: OK.